-Guys, it's the end of the week.
That's usually when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
You know, I check my in-box,
I return some e-mails,
and of course I send out
"thank you" notes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I was running a bit behind.
So I thought,
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd like to write out my weekly
"thank you" notes right now.
Is that cool with you guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I appreciate it.
James, can I get some
"thank you" note writing music,
please?
[ Theme music plays ]
He's in a good mood.
-Wow.
He blinked.
-Hmm.
♪♪
Thank you, Chipotle,
for raising prices.
But if you really want
to make more money,
lower your prices and
start charging for the bathroom.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Nice.
Charging.
♪♪
-Thank you, Mike Pence's
new book, "So Help Me God,"
for sounding less like
the title of a memoir
and more like
what your dad screams
eight minutes into
every family road trip.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, climbing onto
an inflatable pool float,
for basically being
an aquatic sobriety test.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you,
Beyoncé's new album release.
[ Crowd cheers ]
I'm excited, but is it okay
to release something this fire
during a heat wave?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Fire!
-Whoo.
-Wow. [ Imitates explosion ]
[ Explosion ]
-Bey Hive.
-Oh, behave.
♪♪
-Thank you,
watching movies in the park,
for being the best way
not to hear a film
and hurt your back.
[ Applause ]
-[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Thank you, guys who wear
T-shirts in the pool,
for basically saying, "I didn't
want anyone to see my body,
so instead
I vacuum-sealed my torso
under one millimeter
of wet translucent fabric."
[ Laughter and applause ]
You see every curve.
-[ Chuckles ] Oh.
-[ Slurps ]
-Vacuum-sealed.
-Yeah.
♪♪
-Thank you, great Danes,
for letting everyone know
you have a big apartment.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah, we get it. We get it.
The dog is -- Yeah, we get it.
You have a lot of space
for the dog.
♪♪
Thank you, billion-dollar
Mega Millions jackpot,
for making everyone
just a little nervous
that someone they hate will win.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are our "thank you" notes.